[Musique]
un an après la mort de karl lagerfeld
l'entourage du couturier sort du silence
et pourrait bientôt se déchirer sur la
question de l'héritage estimé à
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
en pleine promotion de son livre car les
mois c'est baptiste giabiconi qui le
premier a abordé le sujet de l'héritage
de karl lagerfeld dans les médias une
prise de parole initie le 23 février
dernier dans sept à huit sur tf1
ça veut dire que vous êtes le premier
héritier de 45 à seulement 30 ans
baptiste giabiconi serait donc le
principal héritier de karl lagerfeld
une information qui a rapidement fait
les gros titres de la presse mais
aujourd'hui le dernier numéro du
magazine people voici pense détenir un
scoop par le biais d'un témoignage
anonyme
la rédaction du magazine remet en cause
les déclarations du jeune homme pour eux
la réalité serait différente
tout le monde est très en colère contre
baptiste car elle n'aurait jamais
souhaité qu'on fasse des révélations du
genre c'est une trahison c'est n'importe
quoi il n'est même pas sur la liste des
personnes convoquées chez le notaire
pour l'héritage de son côté public
dément les informations de voici le
magazine qui a contacté les proches de
la star aurait une tout autre version
concernant les affirmations de voici ses
déclarations sont grossières et
mensongère baptiste serait donc bel et
bien sûr le testament tout comme il
l'avait révélé en première place
alors selon vous baptiste giabiconi est
il victime d'acharnement
instant l'ex producteur et manager de
baptiste giabiconi je vous raconterai
tout l'histoire puisque j'ai eu baptiste
giabiconi au téléphone on va revenir le
calme
héritage de caldégas faire une matrice
liberté jamais connu été victime de
harcèlement alors vous rappelle la faire
c'est vrai que dans sept à huit baptiste
avait dit qu'il était euphorique qui il
était voilà le premier héritier de la
famille d ilan et qu'il était très haut
sur la liste alors il ya eu un article
dans voici
ce week end un témoignage publié
vendredi dernier dans le magazine voici
et ils disent que ce serait pas vrai
après ces mois ci on a avec nous side
hajjaji merci side qui a eu un très fair
side car il ya eu un très beau succès
avec surya d'ailleurs de grâce aux voilà
des produits des clips l'album oxygène
de baptiste et vous avez géré sa
carrière de 10 de 2009 à 2017
voilà de combien je vous souhaite
d'avoir la carrière de baptiste
franchement il est excellent alors les
chéris juste si la fortune de karl
lagerfeld c'est combien en bien en vrai
je peux pas donner de chiffres ça c'est
pas d'un milliard dont c'est une très
grosse portion ça c'est clair
allez on peut pas donner d'estimation
part alors à cyril c'est plus un peu
moins mais c'est pas possible ça tenait
à l'or et aux non mais ça c'est ce qu'on
dit généralement quand on vous voit tout
nu car l'aurait aurait-il aimé voilà
légué sa fortune à baptiste où on parle
aussi d'un autre garçon c'est sébastien
jondeau ya un nom qui revient souvent
c'est le garde du corps
l'assistante karl lagerfeld et vous
dites que pour vous c'est lui le
véritable héritier de carnon je dis que
je dis que à travers ces cinq six années
où j'ai produit baptiste et accompagner
baptistan le management d'accor
sébastien jean dos d'une personne
bienveillante vraiment une belle
personne et d'ailleurs je dirais pas
qu'il ya eu un fils spirituel mais il ya
eu deux enfants studio net c'est
baptiste et surtout sébastien on oublie
un peu ses sébastien mais sébastien
parce que sébastien et moi médiatique
donc forcément ils ont tout à fait les
dents longues
il va il est moins connu tout à fait il
est dans l'ombre mais il l'a fait
vraiment et la compagnie carl d'ailleurs
jusqu'au bout et c'est une personne
qu'on doit aussi je pense société alors
l'article 2 voici dit que tout le monde
est très en colère contre baptiste arles
n'aurait jamais souhaité qu'on fasse des
révélations du genre c'est une trahison
c'est n'importe quoi il n'est même pas
sur la liste des personnes convoquées
chez le notaire pour l'héritage
alors est ce que vous y croyez vous à
cette histoire dit la vérité ici gilles
non moi je crois que baptiste est
victime d'acharnement pour répondre à
votre question il ya autour d'eux il y
avait autour de call lagerfeld comme des
clans et là j'ai l'impression que ce qui
m'a gêné chez voici c'est que ces
univoque les sourds sont orientés c'est
pour charger baptiste c'est des gens qui
étaient dans l'entourage qui ont envie
de le faire virer ou 2 ou d'altérer sa
réputation
je sais mais chants anti journalistique
et moi je vous le dit ça m'a choqué et
d'après ce que je sais ça ne repose pas
sur des informations vérifiées alors moi
je vous dire si de ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il ya bien cet héritier sûr on le
voit là le testament d'en accueillir la
lire fun merci et bâtisse est le premier
sur les testaments voilà et apparemment
sébastien serait le deuxième c'est un
testament qu'il a écrits de sa main
la gaffe alors pour être dette on
connaît pas personnellement la liste
d'accords moi j'en fais pas partie ça
c'est clair sinon je crée sur un bateau
mais il n'y a pas de numéro 1 au numéro
2 je pense pas d'accord parce que voilà
bon moi je ne pense pas personnellement
et carla était assis mais là est très
pudique justement sur sur ce genre alors
d'information c'est vrai que je vous le
dis le succès appelle les mensonges et
c'est vrai que battle en ce moment il
est
voilà attaqué de toute part oui j'ai pas
il lève la main je n'ai jamais mettre
dans l'ambiance
mais il la laisse juste comme ça
soit il dit la vérité soit il et fou
relier puisque la vérité va être révélé
regarde mais si on peut continuer
j'imagine pas qu'ils mentent sur un truc
qui va être révélé dans quelques jours
ou alors c'est le cas psychiatrique
alors je le crois et donc je crois qu'il
est victime devient une vraie miss il ya
une très belle relation entre ce
indéniable une superbe aux relations
entre carnet baptiste seckler et
commence à se mettaient à l'achat des
trucs vraiment bien sûr il a vraiment du
talent il a vraiment ce quelque chose
qui fait que on a envie de pousser on a
envie de produire on en redemandait
encore autre chose
non vraiment et je pense que carla vu ça
d'ailleurs quand on a fait un tournage
que j'ai fait un petit tournage vidéo et
un moment là car le disais c'est un
petit diamant brut qui demande aussi
l'aïe et pour être comprendre
mathieu alors comme vous j'ai beaucoup
des futurs beaux bâtisse mais si je mets
ça de côté j'ai été extrêmement choqué
par sa sortie dans sept à huit
parce que bartz avait tous les mois un
public le gode déchets numéro un le
numéro deux et mâcha on a du mal à faire
épier personne pourra vérifier et cela
bien sûr que c'est vérifiable je vais
vous dire pourquoi je vous dire les
avocats de baptiste gd tout ici est de
la succession froid un démenti des
propos de voici
mercredi dans la presse dans le
testament je vous le dis il ya bien bâti
ce numéro un et numéro 2 sébastien
jondeau j'ai les infos bien jouer bach
triste place et voilà week end vous
donnez vous dites que sébastien
accompagner car le jusqu'à la fin est ce
que baptiste aussi la compagnie jusqu'à
la fin où est ce que véritablement comme
on l'a entendu sur les réseaux sociaux
il est fâché avec il était fâché avec
lui depuis cinq années
fâché baptiste est fâché avec qui elle
incarne avec card
je pense pas qu'il soit fâché
l'importance parce que il était non il
était fusionnelle je sais qu'ils se
parlent est constamment on était en
allemagne en promo en allemagne on était
un peu partout ils se parlaient souvent
régulièrement il donnait la portée après
après moi j'ai plus vu au niveau 2 de
sébastien se sait que sébastien
l'accompagner jusqu'à la fin et c'est
quelqu'un qui reste dans l'ombre qui est
un mec formidable vraiment pas lady gaga
voilà et c'est vrai que voilà je vous le
dis moi moi de ce que je sais c'est que
karl lagerfeld est bâti su se sont sûrs
par message vraiment jusqu'au dernier
moment on a vraiment fait ce cadre là
donc je vous dis donc tous les instants
c'est faux l'échec si c'était vrai ce
qu'on entendait est ce qu'on voyait dans
les journaux ça serait un souvenir bien
c'est normal
comment ils savent qu'on bâtit jabbi
coni ça fait vendre que cette histoire
fait vente donc les mettre à fond tout
et n'importe quoi et je vous lis
mercredi il va y avoir un démenti ou
isabelle oui moi je pense que
franchement bac 6 gb conipas malade
mental c'est avec un sentiment immense
façon très intelligente surtout pas que
vous rassurer la promotion du lieu où on
va je me dis que sébastien était celui
qui travaillait au quotidien mecalac
d'offres mais vraiment travailler et que
des [ __ ] n'y était vraiment l'ami de
coeur qui était là pour les sauver ses
militants et ses 25 à garat un fabuleux
sentons très bien aussi avec bâti donc
je vous le dis pour moi vous dire que ce
soit n'a jamais eu de réelle compétition
moi je sais que sébastien a toujours une
bienveillance vis-à-vis de baptiste et
la maman de baptiste
il a toujours été présent ça on ne
pourra pas l'enlever à sébastien il a
toujours été présent pour karl je sais
qu'à certains moments
ainsi à certaines heures ou sébastien
prend la voiture pour aller rejoindre
car elle pour l'aider pour certaines
choses non je pense que vraiment et
pourquoi m et non en trois sets ça que
j'ai pas compter sur l'héritage merci
les séries juste mercredi bâti diaby
coni donc va attaquer ce journal et vous
verrez une fois de plus que ce sont des
conneries qui ont été je pense qu'il a
pris les devants il a regardé devant
baptiste et il dit ça va sortir avec
intérêt de mettre du mais quel intérêt
de se mettre en branle bogosse allait a7
a8 et dire les maisons je suis riche il
ya aucun intérêt à faire ça
si l'affairé a dit rossi je suis numéro
un la mission ressenti là dit il ému
oui maintenant je n'ai jamais cherché
bon call débat là dessus le livre
cartonne en plus de bâtiments merci
d'avoir été avec nous parce qu'il est
venu
[Applaudissements]